ننتقل الان الى هذه الصور المباشره لمرور
لاعبي المنتخب المغربي
ومدربهم في اطار احتفال بانجازاتهم في
المونديال بعد وصولهم منذ نصف ساعه تقريبا
الى العاصمه المغربيه الرباط نشاهد الف من
المواطنين المغربيين
يحتشدون على جوانب الطريق
التحيه على لاعبي المنتخب الذين حققوا
نتائج مشرفه في مونديال قطر 2022 هذه
الحافله المكشوفه يلقي من خلالها اللاعبين
التحيه على هؤلاء
بايطار مواكبه الشرطه والقوه الامنيه
وسيكون هناك يعني احتفال
ومراسم ملكيه
لتكريم نجوم المنتخب المغربي وعشاء سيكون
على شرفهم يجمعهم بالملك
وستحضر امهات اللاعبين هذا العشاء
التكريميه
اذا اعداد كبيره من المغربيين يتجمهرون لي
تكريم
بعثه المنتخب المغربي
احتفالا بانجازهم وتحقيقهم للمركز الرابع
في مونديال قطر للعام 2020